from pillow talk to baby talk
gigi hadid and Zayn Malik are expecting
a little bundle of joy I'm feeling so
overwhelmed with happiness and
excitement that's right he can confirm
that Gigi is pregnant a source tells ET
that Gigi and Zayn are very excited
about starting a family and it's a
secret they've been keeping for a few
months now it's beyond again off again
couple first started dating in 2015 the
pleasure nobody before announcing their
split in March 2018 but in January
rumors started to swirl that the two
were very much back on after they were
spotted together in New York City then
on Valentine's Day Gigi posted this pic
of the former One Direction bandmate
alongside the caption hey Valentine Z on
the farm
he's obviously so gorgeous but really
the way that we could have conversations
and kind of just were really interested
in the same things and it was really
easy now ET source says quote it was
like they never skipped a beat and knew
what they had was special the couple and
their families are overjoyed the two
have been staying at her family's farm
in Pennsylvania where their quarantine
together
amid the corona virus pandemic and they
celebrated Gigi's 25th birthday together
over the weekend the model posted a
series of pics and videos with Zayn her
mama Yolanda and her baby sis Bella
writing sweetest day celebrating my
twenty-fifth birthday with my quarantine
family
[Music]
you